all the Impractical Jokers are here yes
on this this is amazing this is amazing
Ruby's getting comfortable yeah glad you
guys are here
these are heavy yes we're just talking
about the fact that a truTV doesn't seem
to be playing anything except your guys
show these days which is great like I
said I was talking Travis and I were
talking about it like I I went on demand
last night to catch up on episode just
you know before you guys are coming in
and there's only two on demand and I was
like that's any more than two people
aren't demanding it truTV is foreseeing
cuz I turned I was like well let's see
if it's on truTV and said yeah you got
five hours everything you go on to on
request that other men and women guys
watch it if a time when you actually
watch here like I can't do you guys
watch y'all haven't seen the I haven't
seen the earlier yeah I watch it I watch
it with my wife then she skips your turn
she just washes away rhymes me
specifically no I was just looking at
you all your turn I avoid it I don't
wanna watch it you know I don't even
watch the edits you know I can't why you
know what is this is one I see myself
how fat I'm getting over the years so if
they show an earlier season episodes
where I was like 15 pounds lighter
yeah they show a note one now I just
throw up all over myself so I try to
spare myself that fat at all you're
wonderful the narcos by the way wait a
minute
you notice that when you watch TV I've
seen myself like all you ugly
[ __ ] to watch right when you see
your side forget what I look like Jim
yeah I forget that I'm reminded I don't
ever want to know it I understand
completely terrible the first time we
were the first season when it wasn't on
the air yet you don't really think you
like I was making this thing it's on
this cable channel maybe people will
watch it and the first season I did not
even brush my hair anything anything I
refused makeup oh who cares right and
then I watched the whole first season
and I was just in such a whole pit of
despair like this is what I look like in
the second season I like put you know I
comb my hair shallot oh my hair lost a
little bit of weight but now I'm back to
us problem is you know they say the
camera adds 10 pounds where a hidden
camera shows there's eight cameras on us
you know the the woody Kota they we
switched to HD we were in standard
definition and then we liked the second
season they put us in high definition
and that was not good for anybody I
definition body face is for standard no
no comic likes [ __ ] Forte but there's
still more nudity than you would think
yeah yeah there's still I mean I would
think no nudity and there is some nudity
Tate Tate tasteful nude I'm not ashamed
of this bodice what I'm working with is
I used to date a girl who was on the
news she was a newscaster and this is as
the switch was going to HD I used to I
used to just bust her chops
affectionally be like that HD that's
good yeah yeah now that the tables have
turned cuz now I look disgusting and she
still looks great you talk to her oh
time yeah yeah what season what season
are you up to season five is on the air
we're shooting season six now oh my god
so how do you feel like now you're
shooting season six is it like still fun
and the Energy's good or is it like [ __ ]
we gotta come up with another season
thanks but we thought that season two
we're gonna do in season we forgotten
episode two okay yeah I remember she's
in one more like alright well we got
another one like what are we gonna do
but it just keeps coming I mean what we
say we'll do it until we wind up we stop
having fun right we still generally have
fun doing it this is it's actually you
know how like some things like it's not
funny then it comes back sure I'm on the
comeback like season five
a little bit like alright enough but now
I'm having a blast you are yeah so it's
kind of back to being a lot of fun three
days into filming what are you guys like
musicians we're all of a sudden you
start to want to solo up like you know
because musicians whenever you're in a
four-way even radio partnerships it can
be difficult
Renai up and there's four of you a lot
of times would be one guy that goes out
do you guys get that sensation no well
for the most part we we're friends first
so that's where it came from but it's
funny because when people come up to us
in a group they'll come up to like Sal
and live like sell you my favorite it's
just weird could you stand a minute
don't say that your favorite lay it's
strange woman my mother says I think
right now we're in that thing where it's
just like we are kind of all doing
little things here and there but like
financially we will never like we're
stronger together and really all I care
about is money so it's like I just want
to hang on to these guys as long as I do
massive live appearances - yessir people
write checks - Voltron they don't write
checks to just the right leg oh yeah I
give you if you so load up it'd be like
just like you in a grocery store with an
earpiece how I live life normally don't
know soundtrack just credits slowly
rolling do you like the way that you're
portrayed on TV all of you I feel like
they've they've kind of honed in on like
who is the specialty on which I feel
like more like you're like portrayed as
kind of a sociopath
yeah like a non-emotional you know no
moral no ethics
no no it's fun yeah but also the butt of
the joke I get a little bit you know
yeah words I feel like you is like
you're like the softie was like I don't
want I don't want I don't want to do
this why you making me do so I may be a
fat again really works on breakfast
you're not working on at all I have my
sickness now doing great we took like a
out like traits and we just kind of
exaggerated them blow them up a little
bit yeah you know yeah but we're in
charge of the Edit too which helps are
you you are we are start again yeah so
we put we put in we make sure that we
put in what how'd you get that we just
edited
and like nobody else do I know the pain
is there these guys'll do it is great
we're sorry we had no idea to make a TV
show at all and yeah just like they're
like right report to the office we went
there we a little we literally there's
like no desks we sat on a couch and I
looked at each other and like should we
take out our laptop we took our laptops
out here on our like labs and we were
just like writing Joe and then we
started there was only eight people
total and so we called four locations we
did every end from that from and we
thought that was how it's supposed to go
and the next season the show got a
little more popular and they were the
more episodes and then also there was
like more people coming in like what do
you do like yeah I'm the director and
now we have like 50 people and we kind
of get it now but right but you're still
interested you still get to maintain
started doing that and we kind of like
kept it so yeah I don't think they
noticed that we kept it interesting
happened to is like the present Network
I don't want say fired but he got fired
and a new a new regime came in and we
were kind of the hit show already so
there was this kind of thing where they
respectfully weren't like now we're
coming in and changing my show so we
were like oh now we could just seize
power on our own so it worked out pretty
good news yeah they saw Dracula at least
they recognize you guys are doing great
they didn't need to [ __ ] with it that's
awesome that they recognized that I mean
so many people would still kind of get
try to come in and tinker with it alone
they toe the line sometimes with us so
cuz our ideas do get a little bit like
crazy what is one that they said nah
well well for example we've wanted to do
this punishment for years now and they
keep rejecting it on us it's called a
bus to Tampa okay the punishment is
whoever loses the episode we handcuff
him to the back of a Greyhound bus like
inside West's axis we handcuff him and
he's got a drive to Tampa they can't get
off the buses he's got a may you know
survive in the back of a Greyhound to
Temple so rename it call it the old
ratso Rizzo walk in here we want to like
you know just put cams in the bus and it
like the 25 hour ride livestreams yeah I
like piss in jars
yeah yeah oh somebody's legit with like
other people that buy greyhound ticket
so ever since next indoors it with them
and they're all on you know but they
they won't want to do that but why what
are they saying is the problem I think
25 hours of silence they have an issue
we think we'll make great television
yeah there's also the like it so much of
it is spur the moment like I was
watching one last night were you ad
that's why I brought the grocery store
where like you were doing and the little
stupid [ __ ] is what always makes me just
like giggle like they were doing
anything with they were just making them
hijack carts so like they'd be pushing a
grocery cart and then they'd have to go
to somebody who is legit shopping and
just put their cart behind it and just
walk off with their full cart but you
did it to one where there is a kid on it
yeah that's what it gets weird
yeah watching it and then Sal you had to
do it because you had to look at the kid
like you like you were going to cut his
throat if you said anything and I was
like I'm pretty sure if you ask
permission in advance to like fake
kidnap a kid in a grocery store the
network will probably can't we can like
a broad idea and then just kind of
whatever happens happens I'm not above
you know threatening a child have you
ever gotten pissed off at each other cuz
like yeah yeah yeah oh yeah I mean
finish a sentence but because the vibe
is like at the like the comedian's
Norton who hang out in like goof on each
other eventually somebody's going to say
something or catch somebody on a bad day
and get their feelings hurt and it turns
into a real fight correct yeah right
not where you think it's gonna be either
it's not the death of the mother or
something harsh like that yeah you know
it's a had that [ __ ] pilot go that your
shot go [ __ ] about my 12 yeah so like at
what point does that pop up for you guys
it does it with each other every day
mostly cuz we also tour and do live
shows and things like that so with each
other a lot and we whether you know
sometimes worse than others yeah
but then then we go away for a month and
we come back together and we're you know
we're happy again it was you guys we
just started season six with like a some
kind of monster Metallica sit-down where
we talked about our feelings for hours
and hours and and it kind of a group
therapy not really thoroughly I guess
but it's it's not it's but we're really
good friends I mean that's the thing
it's it's we're really close us for so
we're also lovers yeah as friends so so
it's not that hard but you do need that
blowing out of the pipes every once in a
while what what's the what's the other
one what's the thing that will cause
friction more than I think Murray it
generally is one of your price no no no
no him in general I have a particular
sensibility in way of thinking yeah that
is different from most of humanity you
said that most of our are and I won't
even call them fights most of our heated
discussions come from the business
aspect because it's hard because we are
business we're friends business partners
you know co-stars and everything so it's
literally I don't think most of it comes
from like a joke we say to somebody like
we could literally joke about anything
to each other about something but I
think like when we disagree on like the
trajectory we're also all telling you we
were raised in loud houses so when other
people and we have a shorthand talking
to each other so other people from the
outside look at us and seems like we're
screaming at each other but we're just
being passionate yeah right I don't want
to discount my mother's side of the
family I'm half a town we get it is sexy
Latino uh with Cuban mics water Rican I
hear you're half Jewish half
nephew Cuban Puerto Rican Cuban dear
family - yeah would you go yeah I want
to go to Cuba I'm looking forward to
young oh you are going yeah I mean I'm
looking forward to going eventually oh
you should go down there pregnant Cubans
Hey look Wi-Fi really car in 1958 oh my
god I'm hungry
he's a family photo those of us who got
out so how you're doing stand-up yeah
yeah you do stand-up right is anybody
else to stand up now the only one who
was interested in it I think right yeah
you guys never wanted to like we want to
do different things you know like Sojo
oversees most of the TV show you know
he's kind of like that the head guy in
charge and Silver's he's all the edit q
does a lot of the right-hand guy in
charge huh like a change hg I see salad
is stand-up and his excellent Adam has a
college tour coming up this fall yeah q
writes comic books and writes does a lot
of the writing on the show and I an
unmarked Merida novel that he sees
currently flogging yeah he's trying to
get a publisher so we got it it's uh
it's it's a thriller horror takes place
in these subways in a new new mythical
subway line they build under the East
River bars got a very like big sci-fi
brain yes you tell took shape and on
yeah Bella Vita made a slight of frame
murdering his three friends wearing an
earpiece is very very out
but you don't have the ready you guys
don't have TV aspirations to do like
other shows production is well
productions a thing like we like to do
because we're so busy with the show but
we we have a lot of fun ideas that are
out there you know so like TV production
is the other thing that like creating
creating shows your performance working
with people to do stuff we've done that
a bunch since the beginning we've I will
create a few shows here we'll go out and
pitch them we've sold a bunch but
they're gone past pilot but we're always
trying to lower you're trying to you
know work on all the shows and stuff
like that we do guest stars we guest
starring on the shows but we can't
really contractually we can't really
like star in anything else right now oh
I see yeah so but you know always always
irons in the fire dollar area told me to
always say of irons
we're hoping to do a Joker's movie one
day yeah I'm pretty cool I'm sure
they'll you do that you guys are huge
yeah the Prudential Center it's a big
gig yeah yeah what's going on at the
with with the live finale you're doing
the Impractical Jokers live Nitro Circus
spectacular lightning things very easy
to then people remember it short and
easy done a third in November at the
Prudential Center our our season finale
and it's going to be a live two-hour
episode where we partnered with Nitro
Circus those crazy guys to do those
motorcycle stunts and everything and
we're not stuntmen annoying or Craven or
no athletic
it's gonna be like a middle-aged wipeout
yeah last year we did a live episode
which went really well and was a lot of
funds who are like oh we want to do that
again so we said could we do that again
for a finale so it's kind of like
they'll again we could get the
Prudential Center in Nitro Circus or
like okay let's do that but they're yeah
they're they're good group to work with
the ideas that we have or we'll all
survive I think I think of it but you
guys have other people try to give you
ideas I'm sure friends iconic you they
give you jokes you want to just [ __ ]
smash well you got some but you have
that way guys give you ideas like look
which is a comedy show we can't pull
that off yeah we get that a lot I mean
it's not just friends it's really anyone
who seen us on the street at all at any
time any point it just come up and like
yeah this is what you guys should be
doing what's an idea that someone gave
you like we just can't ever do that
Oh somebody actually wants picture said
Elijah at our live shows would you like
meet and greets at the end and there's a
lady comes in she's like you guys should
be surgeons
and I said oh I was like oh well you
know like play we played doctors before
she's like no no you should get the
punished I to be like assisting in a
surgery I was like like a real surgery
where somebody's like yeah because you
wouldn't know what to do when the guy
said hand me this he wouldn't know what
to hand them that's a release to get you
talking into the earpiece say she's got
nice are you saying do you want it like
get each other punched in the face
sometime when you're doing these things
I don't think that a goal I mean I
wanted I want them to like go through
endure whatever the worst of it is but
we kind of like stray from getting to a
heated point we kind of in the beginning
we push those boundaries a little but
it's kind of sometimes it hits a point
where it's not funny yeah it's like if
someone's pissed off and they want to
punch you it's more like oh [ __ ] is you
gonna punch him but it strays away from
funny and you can antagonize anyone yeah
yeah that's not this kind of like it's
easy almost so I think what we try to do
is toe the line between confusing people
confounding people and then just kind of
like or just creating a situation where
people are like a little bit incredulous
and stuff like that
what could I I watched Q tell a guy to
stop looking at his tips look at his
eyes and the guy like was obviously like
I'm not [ __ ] around like go yeah
enough enough and Q walked away [ __ ]
sure and I told you take a shirt off is
the only time you take a shirt off on
the TV show actually no no it's in the
Sal's window cells window tears broke
you got a massage naked yeah yeah are
you with something like that happened to
you I'm straight up as I'm in charge of
the attitude let's just assume if you
don't be hard on yourself but you are a
human piece of [ __ ] is a custom I'll be
hearing a funny prank idea by the way
what's something I've always wanted to
do for real what is right this is true
but where I get a massage a legit
massage with a hidden camera but no you
tell there's a camera there doing from
this and then I signal my I drink milk
before and I [ __ ] fart through the
whole massage
ha ha I mean I signal real quick and
then you know when I'm in a fart and
then you just see it for face changes I
want that to be a three-hour Christmas
when I went to the Prudential Center
we uh we we work as uh not we were
getting massages from professional
massage therapists and we had selling
them and we'd secretly planted
underneath his massage table one of
those machines you press the button it's
an app you know hit the app and then it
farts and and he visit barrassed ah man
no I got a feeling your idea I know you
want to foil but I didn't see that I I
thought you were gonna tell the story
the reverse we were we were on the road
and we sold out two shows and as a thank
you the the owner the clubs okay I'll
send over a masseuse T a hotel so she
shows up with a with a table and so she
she's two of them in his four of us so
they do who became her first at South my
lady's gonna Sal neck so she's massaging
me in the whole time she is just farting
and trying to cover with a call but
we're in a quiet hotel room so I'm legit
she's legit gonna and right and back and
I'm just sitting in I'm laughing and I'm
just trying to hold together and at the
end she's like oh how was it I went I
just ripped the loudest fall I was only
I was like it was great so that Sal text
me and he's like dude and he's like I'm
kind of tired should she come I'm like
dude you have to have her it was an
unbelievable massage so I said a fun
lately down to Sal's working and no joke
guys she didn't she didn't fart in front
of me she was it was complete silence
sorry I heard a stomach go he didn't
tell me any of this I heard a stomach
going up stomach oh my wow it's like
abnormally loud and then she says can I
have a minute
yes I can she went so I've had [ __ ]
she's in it but it was loud it hurt her
[ __ ] you're paying for that time you pay
her absolutely back out like it was
nothing and continued it and I call my
Tucci like excuse insolvent shipment I
wish tears I tears go you on your
stomach crushing your heart on it
I wanna tell ya I was pressed up against
the bathroom door I had a girl I had a
hook at one time [ __ ] I oh she's coked
out sugar coke [ __ ] at my apartment I've
never had a massage diapers do it's
creepy listen coach [ __ ] just like a
liquidy and you could tell she was all
wired up and you're cold yeah [ __ ] oh
yeah was not a good time thank you for
explaining that because I had a
different image in my head you had like
over a Sunday I was gonna ask you
yeah cute when somebody like it comes
back at you aggressively when you're
doing one of the pranks do you kind of
come back and him like a [ __ ] you it is
it's normally no because first and
foremost we're trying to make the TV
show so we want to make sure they're
gonna sign so if they're getting angry
like you want to pull it back and get it
to a comfortable place so he'll sign
degree and be on TV and still be funny
that guy you're talking about annoy the
[ __ ] out of me and like that's when the
the Staten Island New York is like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I mean then I just start
doubling down and and like like trying
to annoy the guy and like like try and
piss him off but he signed that guy in
the end so you know that he was his face
was blurred out he's blow it inside out
what we do is we have really attractive
raw crew is really attractive but like
there's me send them too so like someone
needs to sign if it's a guy like we'll
send over a good-looking girl it was
funny when we were setting up the intros
that they're setting the cameras and
they're focusing everything so they have
four stand ins crew members standing in
our place before we have to go over to
be on camera and the four standings off
battle should absolutely be on TV more
than good-looking man we have to wrap
Travis is giving us the signal I guess
that's not ours that's the TV oh you
have to go but the Impractical Jokers
live Nitro Circus spectacular somebody
could die
you don't know seeker you know no you
should talk it out it's live so right
November that's a massive gig you got
I've done gigs on the road and then you
like you do a small theater then you
walk by the main theater and you see all
Impractical Jokers
December 8 through 14
guys it never ends because now we're in
the middle theater we walk by it's like
Amy Schumer next week yeah that's the
arena yeah yeah so the finales November
3rd at 8 p.m. it's at the Prudential
Center
I guess tickets are available yeah don't
forget yeah check it out if you're local
and cute you're a big wrestling fan
right love it yeah anybody else oh yeah
yeah yeah we go anytime they're in town
we go and I was on the edge and
Christian show the finale last season
but we've become really like Chris
Jericho's my favorite like I have such a
crush on that guy he's so good right now
he's maybe watching on Twitter Oh daddy
blocked me he would be so happy
I don't know I'll tell you I like I stay
in touch with you for your rustling
uh-oh
Thank You yetis yeah he blocked me on
Twitter because somebody made up a quote
that I said I can't just tweeted it to
him and he was like like screw you and
your afro say I'm the head a block
stupid it'll block Diane snow blocks
yeah I'm going to talk to ya I mean
would you yeah yeah find out if you
actually man okay
I can't imagine he's mad he's such a
sense of humor that guy yeah I want to
know if he's doing bad guy wrestling
stick on Twitter or like say I'm like
yeah I want to know do any of the
wrestlers like the show oh my god so
many people backstage they're like we're
excited to meet them and but they're
like asking for pictures with us so I'm
just like that's amazing oh it's great
yeah that's amazing yeah
it's been cool because you grew up
watching wrestling and then did we have
like a connection to them now like we
were trying to do some stuff with them
and you know what the WB and then we'll
go back there and everyone's like we
love that it's like oh my god my friends
are restless so when you see them do
their prank show swerved are you like we
could have [ __ ] done that what do you
guys want to do it with them when the
schedule just didn't work out and I
think Paige tried the Larry bit on the
show yeah yeah and it didn't it didn't
pan out like like we wanted it to I shot
I shot a weird print with Hulk Hogan it
was black and white
it was fresh
I'm also white alright alright we'll let
you guys go thank you